here to explain what Republicans can
actually get done in a new Congress
Florida Congressman Byron Donalds and
Michael Waltz uh Congressman Donalds let
me let me start with you you heard my
conversation with Tulsi uh we do know
what's going on at the border I'm still
concerned that the majority of the
Americans maybe don't realize the
severity of what's happening at the
border they keep getting gas lit by
Biden and Kareem Jean-Pierre says the
borders closed no it's not and this is a
dramatic having a dramatic impact on
every American's life so what can in
January what will the Republicans do
considering what's happened with now the
the spending Bill what what's on tap
here what can we expect sir
well look first of all it's good to be
with you Merry Christmas to everybody I
share your concerns because it's not
just the administration it is the big
media that has conditioned the American
people to not understand the
complexities of what's happening at the
border you couple that with the Senate
deal which was passed basically with a
twink and a nod uh allowing this program
to continue House Republicans are going
to be hamstrung by this spending bill
because what are the leverage points to
actually require the Biden
Administration to actually secure the
Border a couple things that can be done
number one give border agents the
ability to make credible threats of fear
at the border number two don't allow
people to make Asylum claims at the
southern border if you do those two
things that will actually limit the
capabilities of people to use the drug
cartels to come into the United States
but it's not a good situation in part
media and yet Senate Republicans them
passing this Omnibus deal with the
Democrats have really put us is behind
the eight ball about what to do with
border security well you know
Congressman Waltz this is where you do
have to get creative you know we see the
Democrats all the time being very
creative you've got to give them you
know some credit for that there's got to
be ways to achieve certain things using
other parts of the budget using other
kinds of legislation what do you see
happening starting in January
well I agree with everything
representative Donald said but I think
we need to take things even a step
further we need to designate these
cartels that are behind all of it as
either a terrorist organization or a
terrorist-like organization great idea
we need to put sanctions and these
companies that we know are producing
fentanyl as part of their asymmetric
Warfare to kill Americans working with
international criminal organizations
including the Mexican cartel so that's
step two and then you know personally as
a member of the armed services committee
and as a veteran we need to be using
military assets I'm not talking boots on
the ground but cyber space assets and
other things that we can be doing to jam
the cartels
disrupt their organization go after
their money and shut them down we did it
years ago to the cartels in Colombia and
we can do it again if we have the will
and then finally Tammy there is going to
be a North America American leader
Summit on January 9th and 10th with
Trudeau Biden and president obrador that
is an opportunity right there to put
Mexico on notice that they need to put
their National Guard on their southern
border stop shipping these migrants
through to create our problem and that
we're going to put remain in Mexico back
in place I doubt we're going to see that
from Biden but all three will be sitting
down Trudeau's talking about electronic
or electric vehicles and climate we have
to talk about humanitarian crisis
January 9th and 10th North American
leader Summit called The Three Amigos
Summit but we'll see and this is where
for for representative Donalds I mean I
think that this is an opportunity where
if you're waiting for men like that to
do something it's useless it's hopeless
that Congress that House Republicans can
have some kind of an action or a
delegation or a demand or some
legislation on the heels of that we're
you know there's got to be something
creative to push this along we know that
the House of Representatives of the
United States government has power and
and the Republicans have to wield it
well look Tammy I'm going to tell you
the next big vehicle in my view that's
going to come across might be the debt
ceiling that might be the next big one
whatever that Leverage is whatever that
lever is in Congress we need to make
sure that we make border security the
number one thing that's on the agenda
and so for you know my colleagues on the
other side of the Iowa who now all of a
sudden want to start talking about the
Border because the midterm elections are
now or now over I asked them where have
you been where were you in August
September and October
um immigration policy per se is not the
issue it is about securing the border
and where my colleague is absolutely
correct the drug cartels are going to
make 15 billion dollars this year
trafficking people and Fentanyl into the
United States of America it is
unconscionable and we must stand with
whatever that lever is we need to use it
to make sure we secure the Homeland here
in the United States you know gentlemen
the American people gave the Republicans
the house of rep representatives for a
reason they want to see something happen
this is a test this is not a hard test
right we just need to implement the law
as it stands and fund the ability for
the border patrol and law enforcement in
general to do their jobs uh gentlemen
Congressman thank you very much for
joining me tonight hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else